what is that culture of like street
chess players it seems it seems pretty
interesting like um
i don't know that seems to be
celebrating the beauty of the game it's
the trash talking but also having fun
with it but also taking it seriously
and you've done a few of those you go to
new york yeah in union square park
washington square what was that like
it's such a unique place i haven't seen
it anywhere else in the us where people
are just
professional chess hustlers even if
they're not necessarily you know a top
player but they play chess every single
day and so many of them learn chess by
themselves and never had a professional
coach so they are quite good at it
they're also very tight-knit they all
know each other and it's a very social
thing where you're not just playing
chess it's the experience of getting to
know this person who's
very much a personality and they talk to
you they could either give you tips or
they could be really chatty and talk to
you during so it's a chess experience
rather than just playing a game do you
tell them like what your rating is or do
you just let people just like off
both ways do you discover how good the
actual the person actually initially i
loved going and not telling people my
rating and just surprising them and and
winning games but now we've gone so many
times that they just know us so we can't
get away with it anymore one time
actually i don't know if i should share
this but one time
we dressed up as grandmothers and we had
prosthetics on our face yeah and i think
they still recognized us
yeah it's probably the
there's other components like probably
the trash talk and all that
actually no it was funny we were talking
like grandmothers but it was the way i
held
it was the way grandmother
talked like you don't want to say no no
no
no we're not bringing you once
we're not bringing
okay what were your names what were the
code names oh my god i think it was edna
edna and i had a really uh i can't
remember the other one
but it was embarrassing because we were
walking so slowly and andrea dropped her
cane or something at one point then
people in the park they were to help her
and we felt so handsome
but but yeah it was funny because they
didn't know it was us until he saw the
way i reached for my pawn and he said
the way you held your pawn i knew it was
you it was like such a sneesh thing that
was what blew the grandma cover
uh yeah do you have a style of how you
play physically
is that i didn't think we did until
grandma went to play chess but yeah i've
never thought about that yeah i think
our style is just trash talking now
it's style is very if you're talking
about style
on and youtube and twitch we definitely
have a distinctive style what's that
what's your distinction just talking
[ __ ]
but not going too far no no definitely
that's that's definitely going to if
it's us two against each other oh we we
trash talk each other so hard so and i
love looking at andrea like watching her
nose scrunch up as she's annoyed and the
satisfaction i get when that happens
how many times do you play against each
other on online publicly i think i've
seen a couple of games played a lot of
times we try not to do it too often
because it's repetitive but every now
and then when we haven't done it for a
while we'll go at it again what do you
mean repetitive is like is that implied
trash talk right there no it just we we
place similar openings so you just start
seeing the same position you offer each
other every time
andrea's really good at opening so i
just start playing bad openings to get
her out of her preparation because i
don't like opening theory very much i
just like playing the game and getting
into middle
games and end games but yeah typically
the only time we're playing each other
is when we're setting up in the park and
we don't have opponents yet and we need
content so we just play each other until
people show up but we always put stakes
on the line which make it more very
interesting because otherwise it
wouldn't be fun to play each other if
there's no stakes where's where is the
most fun place you've you've played is
in new york i think so and it was
actually when we set up in times square
one night we just brought a table with
us and chess and it's not even where
people usually play chess but it was
so lively there were all of the lights
out and so many people just kept
stopping by to play chess and it was
really one of my favorite streams just
the opposite of like the classical chess
world it's super loud there's music
there's cars there's street dancers even
some naked people walking around who we
had to be careful not to get banned yeah
but i honestly really like the chaotic
environments for chess games because i
think it's a good way to break more into
the mainstream culture and make it
entertaining and appealing to anyone who
doesn't know anything about chess
um
and also in an authentic way because
it's what we really like about chess
when you're just enjoying the game but
also the atmosphere and the people who
you're playing with and that's one of
the things that i think you see less
when you're just thinking of chess as a
competitive thing
you